whatever you do don't be rude to the
people handling your food because you
might find a pubic hair in your burger
how do you get something for free BYOB
bring your own bug complain first off
but you don't even have to complain that
much you don't even have to make a scene
open the package and take one bite of
the food and then return it and they
can't take it back over the counter most
of the time so you're just gonna get
free food that way some of the managers
at some of the spots sometimes they have
coupons that they have in their back
pocket and they give out whenever they
feel like they're in good spirits so if
you see a manager you're welcome to a
spot be nice what time is best to order
food the best time to order food is
right when they open breakfast you want
to order it as early as possible if you
get breakfast towards like the end of
the breakfast time you're getting the
worst oldest stay list grossest eggs
ever you're getting them nasty if you're
gonna be buying food for lunch or dinner
you want to do that outside of the rush
hour because the rush hour is when we
don't pay attention to the quality of
the food do ice cream machines really
break all the time
they're the worst machines ever made
they get jammed nobody likes them we
hate that you buy ice cream sometimes
like we don't have people who either
don't know how to use a machine
sometimes people are just lazy and don't
feel like walking over to the Machine
and they'll lie and say it's broke are
you told to fill cups with ice on
purpose or not fill up cartons with
fries to the top we're gonna fill up a
lot of ice in that cup because you're
gonna get less soda you're gonna go to a
place go to one where you can get your
own soda out of the machine because
that's the only way to cheat the system
on that for fries if we haven't made a
new batch and it's like the scraps of
the last batch you know we'll just try
to get what's last in there we always
always always didn't film to the top we
did that on purpose
if we ever did it we got in trouble our
boss did not like that what are the
consequences if you put soda in a free
water cup diabetes you get arrested
immediately no I'm kidding
they don't do anything at all don't do
the brown sodas because then it doesn't
look
as conspicuous if your there's a manager
standing by you maybe they might call
you out and you might get a little shame
award a cup shaming are the employees
must wash hand sign more of a reminder
for you or to make customers feel better
it's for all of us
we shouldn't have to remind you as
adults to wash your hands but we all
should just wash our hand they think
that signs just gonna throw it out there
and make the customers immediately think
oh of course they're washing their hands
they're so hygienic yeah that's not
always the case there are some people
that might not wash their hands because
they wear gloves and might just put on
gloves on top of their dirty hands like
Oh what do I need to wash my hands for
you idiot you just put on gloves with
your dirty hands so if you're ever
seeing anybody handle your food make
sure that they're wearing gloves every
single time I'm not gonna tell you why
I'm just gonna say make sure they're
wearing gloves our names misleading dis
fresh always mean fresh names being
misleading yeah there's a lot of fake
lines that are put on those burgers to
think that they're going through a flame
they're not there's no fire that touches
those things have you ever created your
own secret menu what was it if you're
lactose intolerant like me and you don't
want cheese on your baked potato
barbecue sauce is the way to go it's
like a big giant barbecue potato chip I
would always get like the ice cream
concoctions I would throw salty stuff in
it like fries because I'm fat and
customers saw that I made that and they
wanted it but we couldn't make it for
him because it wasn't actually on the
menu you just get creative you make some
spicy with some sweet some hot with some
cold and just see what you come up with
the combinations are endless what's the
most annoying thing you get asked daily
how many patties are in a double
cheeseburger ordering on the phone is
annoying because either you're trying to
talk to me or you trying to talk to the
other person you know they're from
Canada when they want Mayo for their
fries that's disgusting be nice to the
people that are making your phool got it
one more time for the people in the back
be nice to the people that are making
your food cuz they're making your food
like seriously and you're not sitting
there watching what they're doing